how are you Andy good how are you doing
I'm doing fine did we go to camp
together because Andy kamenetsky sounds
just like a guy went to camp with we are
like I found like a guy that a lot of
people went to camp with okay but we
never went to camp you never went to
camp right under trails in camp and
never went there Andy no no I was a Tom
sock guy in Leicester bill Missouri okay
Wow in the nation's heartland okay Andy
yes all right now that we've checked
that box that nobody thought needed
checking whatever what are the Lakers
doing right now do you think as you and
I are conversing I think right now they
are at the very least buying into the
the reports that you know they're
hearing that LeBron has concerns about
the team that he's signing up for not
necessarily that he's having second
thoughts about being a Laker but the
idea that he would just be the first
person to commit and it seems like
whether you're talking about LeBron
James Paul George you know a trade that
would involve Kawhi Leonard nobody
necessarily wants to be the first and if
you're LeBron you have the type of juice
where you can put that leverage on the
Lakers and say you bring in Kawhi
Leonard I'm definitely in
if Kawhi is not there before I make a
decision when creation C opens might
still be there but it's not the same
definite but it would have been so what
we can definitely glean from all this
Andy is what is that the idea that
LeBrons coming to the Lakers because he
wants to be part of a an organization
with a loss history in Los Angeles where
he has a home and in an industry that he
he's already successful in for a
post-playing career that that's out the
window we're talking about roster and
winning well I think I think if you're
LeBron if you're the type of person that
can quite literally have anything you
want you want it to be the most things
possible and I do think that there's a
part of LeBron if he's considering the
Lakers or decides to go to them he is
thinking about transitioning out of
basketball and what his life is going to
be like for his family what it's going
to be like for him you know moving
further into the entertainment industry
that he's already laid down roots but at
the same time you want to have as many
good seasons as possible and be as close
to contention as you can be and the
Lakers offer a lot more flexibility in
the way
they can build a roster for LeBron as
opposed to say Cleveland that's pretty
stock I mean they can look to make some
moves but they don't have a lot of
assets and LeBron has seen them run it
back a few times and their hands are
pretty tied the Lakers have a lot more
fluidity in terms of what they could do
Andy kamenetsky the athletic ESPN Radio
covering the Lakers joining me here on
the show so what are though I mean
you're hearing that the Lakers are
pretty much giving up anything not
nailed down to make Kawhi Leonard happen
what are you hearing well I mean what I
think is really fascinating about this
rich is the idea that the Spurs the
Spurs seem to have gone from really
wanting to make this work with Kawhi to
recognizing that it's not going to work
and also recognizing the leverage that
LeBron may have indirectly given them by
putting the pressure on the Lakers so
you've got this window before free
agency begins for the Lakers to
potentially convince San Antonio this is
the best offer you're going to get and
that being the case
sanika USA today use the word Godfather
describing the rumored offers you're
talking I assume about a Brandon Ingram
kuzmic included in there maybe Josh Hart
as well
future pick I mean that's a very very
good haul for San Antonio but what I
also think is interesting is the idea
that they can't get this done before
free agency begins if I'm San Antonio I
wait to see what Paul George does
because there is a lot of chatter that
Paul George could potentially decide to
stay in Oklahoma City he said a lot of
great things about it a lot of people
who cover the team say he genuinely has
enjoyed it and is making a decision and
if Paul George did decide to stay in
Oklahoma City that gives the Spurs much
more confidence to sit to think that
another team it's Boston Celtics
Philadelphia 76ers might take a chance
on trading for Kawhi even if all they're
hearing from his team is he's going to
be a Laker he's going to be a Laker it's
exactly what Paul George set and then in
theory he ends up staying in Oklahoma
City well so is there an untouchable on
the Lakers roster I mean he use another
gangster movie phrase here for you know
it's funny cut to or go back a year ago
and Brandon Ingram was being described
as borderline untouchable and Lonzo ball
was before he had even put on a summer
league uniform was being described as
the transcendent face of the
organization magic saying you know leave
me a few of my records don't don't break
em all there Alonso and over the course
of here everybody is a little bit more
touchable I mean I think they genuinely
like all these kids I mean even in a
perfect world I think they'd like to
have Julius Randle around it and and
Randle is the most likely candidate to
end up gone if they end up with a super
team just from the cap issues alone but
I think they like all these kids but at
the same time like my personal opinion
is that Brandon Ingram should be the
most untouchable of all I think Brandon
Ingram has the best combination of
versatility work ethic physical gifts
potential you can play him one through
four possibly but what are the odds that
he ends up as good as a healthy Kawhi
Leonard even if you think Brandon Ingram
is going to be very good and I and I
really do the odds don't favor that
because Kawhi Leonard is an MVP caliber
player that's right so there's nobody on
the roster you don't give up to get
Kawhi Leonard if that means that you to
get a commitment from LeBron and I think
it's I think it's really a question of
how much you give up individually I
would imagine that they all could be on
the table it's just a question of okay
do you really give them all up you know
do you truly gut yourself not just of
players but of other assets to help
build around the theoretical team of
LeBron James Kawhi Leonard maybe even
call George like you you're leaving
yourself not just few players along the
margins but actual few assets to help
bring more in so Andy kamenetsky the
athletic ESPN Radio Land o Lakers comm
and also at cam brothers on Twitter
covering the Lakers so
I guess then where do we go from here
the easier possibility get all three the
the motherlode Paul George
LeBron and Kauai fitted under a cap have
enough players still left to to win now
Andy is that possible well I mean it's
possible to make the mechanic's workers
get all three you've got to find a way
to get blue all dang off your books oh
yeah I don't even think stretching and
would be enough you need to find a taker
for Luol which again requires some of
these young assets that you wouldn't
want to give all up to San Antonio in a
potential trade it would be more
difficult to build around those three I
mean we've seen him with Golden State
with their you know they've got an
amazing big fork but you start getting
past you know Andre Iguodala and Shaun
Livingston there's not a whole lot there
if it's the Miami Heat went through this
for years you know Cleveland's dealing
with it now any when you have that
top-heavy of a roster it's difficult to
find quality seven through nine guys who
you know who actually really do matter
but the flipside is LeBron James Kawhi
Leonard Paul George it's a hell of a big
three I mean you're you're going to be
looking to take your chances against a
team like Golden State with that I mean
that bit that is a team that is built to
defend what Golden State does and do all
the switching and have the athleticism
and the length that they're built to
take on Golden State so you would look
to take your chances with now you also
got a figure right now Lakers clearly
can't reach out to any of the players
that we're talking about right now but
LeBron James sure can he's got Paul
George's number I'm sure he can call
Kauai right now and get these ducks in a
row and then leave up the details to to
magic and and and and pálinka to figure
it out so do you think LeBron hops out
tomorrow that's what it all comes down
to okay I I do think he opted out I mean
unless he decide unless he decides at
the last minute that he you that he's
actually interested in forcing a trade
to say Houston I don't see a lot of
scenarios where it makes sense for
LeBron to opt out it I mean opt in it
seems to me that he would want to have
as much flexibility as possible you can
always go back to Cleveland hmm so I I
would find it very say
surprising mifflin did not opt it out
and become a free agent tomorrow and how
did you how did you and the rest of the
Lakers media team take the I guess
surprise move of magic taking a page out
of the gym bus lexicon and basically
saying if I don't get it done you you
know I'm out I should be out that was
really surprising I mean it's the
showmanship that you associate with
magic even if you could argue it wasn't
necessarily the smartest move I mean
there's no real upside to putting
yourself on a clock that publicly that
definitively if you don't have to and it
makes you think that magic either knows
something you know I mean he through the
back channeling and through the Intel
gathering he knows something he knows
what's going to happen and that's where
you make a statement that definitive and
that confidently or you worried that he
perhaps thinks he knows something which
isn't the same thing as knowing
something and he's possibly the guy who
either misread the room or he's the guy
at the card table who thinks that he has
the nut flush and doesn't realize that
he misread one of those clubs and it's
actually a spade and he just pushed all
his chips in with the wrong hand but I
mean it's the type of confidence that
frankly you expect from Magic Johnson
Magic Johnson has done an awful lot of
winning over the course of not just his
career but his life I mean the guy has
pretty much conquered anything you put
in front of him other than a talk show
so it's easy to understand where magic
would say yeah I can put myself out
there because I know I'm gonna win this
is Who I am
and Lonzo looks jacked man I mean he's
like I'm serious it looks like he is he
has taken to heart and he'd what needs
to be done to improve and in year two
and I but I do notice he's not his name
isn't being bandied about on any of
these to go to the Spurs and I'm drawing
a line between him and his dad on that
front is that is that a is that off-base
but you know I think it's exactly the
way I interpret it as well I was
actually at the Lakers game where the
Spurs were visiting and I was part of
the scrum and I actually asked
Popovich his thoughts on Lavar and the
the statements that he made that the
team that Luke Walton was losing the
team and Popovich teed off on him
you know Popovich Gregg Popovich made it
clear he thinks lavars a clown he thinks
he's a loudmouth he thinks he has no
idea what he's talking about and
assuming Gregg Popovich is going to be a
part of the Spurs moving forward and
maintains the same amount of sway that
he has with the front office and
decision making I would find it very
surprising if he would sign up to
essentially team up and deal with
everything that comes with Lavar ball I
don't think it has anything to do with
Lonzo me I think he thinks lonzo's a
good player I I hear very few actual
complaints about Lonzo with his actual
personality it's really all an extension
of Lavar I mean you can make a very
strong argument I've always said this a
big baller brand it's really a Lavar
ball brand in right the way it's being
presented right now it doesn't have much
to do with even Lonzo much less the
other two kids you know it's all about
Lavar ball and most teams if not all of
them aren't going to want to deal with
that unless they really have to well and
then this is my last one for you because
it's something that LeBron would be
opting into saying with Paul George if
if if if they so they both decide to
come to the Lakers is what is the Lakers
relationship with Lavar right now
because everything I'm reading is that
they had to have some form of a ginger
process to let him know Lee Angelou is
not on the summer team roster and yeah I
mean you maybe it's a ginger process but
at the same time they did it you know I
mean a year ago it might have been more
easy for them to imagine automatically
giving that spot to Lee Angelou
specifically because of the way they
were hyping up Lonzo but also because
they hadn't had as much history with
lebar the fact that they would you know
the fact that they don't give Lee
Angelou or Summerlee there's a summer
league spot it's obvious in the sense
that he's not good enough for their
summer league roster I mean you would be
taking up a spot he would he's not good
enough to really contribute but it also
can be seen as a line being drawn in the
sand in a sense of there's only so much
we're going to do
to make you happy to potentially make
Lonzo happy and you need to you need to
send signals that levar does not call
the shots for this organization I mean
you know ultimately if you bringing
LeBron LeBron is gonna have a lot of
juice but he's LeBron you know levar is
not LeBron and to this point Lonzo is
not LeBron so if LeBron has outside an
outsized influence over the organization
that goes with the territory but that
can't be levar ball and appreciate the
time great stuff let's chat again soon
absolutely thank you you got Andy
kamenetsky the athletic and ESPN radio
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience